the drone didn’t fly right here,
you closed the space
so it didn’t reach us at all,
just a little bit. It’s amazing that it landed
here now, there was such an explosion,
wow,
you just shook the asphalt, my
heart is still beating, it
happened exactly at 10:36 I was walking to  I
was late for work, as always, and a sharp explosion
occurred, you know, as if the asphalt
was rubbing cars. They immediately began
to evacuate from such a stream of a strong
explosion, my clothes were just blown away. I
was in shock. I had no thoughts at that moment, I
immediately ducked down because I understood that it
had naturally arrived, and the first thought was
that it was a drone.  you bend down and look and
see an insanely huge explosion, so I took a
video of this explosion and a puff of smoke at
my workplace. When I came to my
workplace on the keyboard there was
such a sprinkled ceiling, that is, it was
also
reflected on the buildings, the windows felt the walls and
now I have this dust from the ceiling at my
workplace  there was a powerful explosion on the table
and it was heard by
all the colleagues in the office, even those whose windows didn’t
go out on this side, so
the destruction of the strong No, it was just very
scary, the sound of the
car was standing Well, like a motor
and in the end it was 2 minutes and there was an explosion of cotton. That
is, he was scared right with the pressure
here then it’s all Awareness comes,
but in the end it still works out and the police
went
and started the coastal zones there, it turns out to
be boats So Boris said what he
said, he was flying, he says, well, it’s as if
his motor had already died, or these are
how they cut off these waves,
radio waves, waves  and that's all, and he says
cotton, he says he shook it too